my name is Alec Amidon glycerin and from
Argentina living in between Mexico on
and as with ha where do I see the battle
may can be hung on 2050 and I think this
region with would call us a lot based on
on all the commodities in halves I see
differences between countries in Latin
America some are taking the opportunity
make a huge improvement people are under
development such as Mexico and Colombia
Uruguay nasal and I see other countries
that when they needed political change
to realize this opportunities they have
megan is sending commodities to the rest
of the world those countries i see
lagging behind our venezuela and athena
and ecuadorian and the challenges they
are facing some are related to violence
like in Mexico when but mainly the point
so the countries will develop at
different places according to the
political atmosphere